wir von der heute show haben natürlich
versucht uns für diesen als der
parteitag in köln zu akkreditieren aber
merkwürdigerweise noch keine antwort
gericht vermutet dass in der post
verloren gegangen aber kein problem wir
haben unsere investigativ granate dennis
clausthaler längst ins tagungshotel
eingeschleust wo er denn ich sehe keinen
den ich bereits in diesem perfekten
kostüm in frauke petry zimmer gestellt
hat keiner gemerkt
heute morgen hat ist die putzfrau sogar
gegossen und somit droht der frau des
glücks während des kriegs geheimen
programmentwurf für die bundestagwahl
gefunden
kapitel 1 konzepte die deutschen nach
vorne bringen
da hat sie ein bild von sich selbst und
ganz oft das wort ich geschrieben
noch mehr bilder von ihr noch mehr
bilder von noch mehr
das ist ein bild von ihrem mann hat sie
ein bild von bernd rücken gemalt ganz
gut getroffen für mich also ist sie
tatsächlich völlig zerstritten
das kann man wohl sagen die hatten sich
inzwischen mehr als ausländer hinter dem
stacheldraht ende das petrihaus dagegen
dass alexander gauland lager bewacht von
seiner privaten security der gastgarten
heil hitler
beckett beim parteitag schmuggelt nicht
in den großen sitzungssaal
ich fürchte mit dem kostüm wird das aber
nichts mit dem nicht aber mit dem hier
[Applaus]